Hello and welcome to this video on NavMesh Proxy's automatic placement.
Now this is a feature which is new for version 5.5 Unreal Engine and this allows us to
automatically create nav links. So if I start off here you can see we have
our characters stuck up on this block and if I stop we cannot we cannot get off there.
So the normal process would be to add in a whole load of nav links to each of these areas.
However if you wanted to do this automatically what you would need to do is select the Recast
NavMesh up in our options here and we're going to search through my closed down display.
Under generation we actually have a tick box for generate nav links.
If I was to tick that on you can see what happens we've now got a whole load of different
nav links from in logical places. So if I push play you can see that our character can now
get down off the ledge. Unfortunately we have the same problem that we have
with our nav link proxies that it's only telling them that these areas are connected.
It's not necessarily allowing them to have any functionality to get up to.
So we want our character to jump. Now we would do this in a very similar way to
what we were previously working on. What we're going to do is we're going to create a smart
link and add in the functionality to make the character jump. It's a little bit different.
For example what we need to do is when we need to make a blueprint and it needs to be
of the parent type generate nav link proxies we have here. Now I don't want to go through the
process again of putting one of these together but I will show you an example of a finished one.
So as you can see here this is my generated nav link proxy and we will automatically have
the event event receive smart link reached. This functions in exactly the same way as
our standard nav link. Now what I'm going to do in this is pretty much exactly the same
functionality as we had in the previous video. Connected up we're going to calculate the
velocity and launch the character and that will make it fire up into the air. Now in order for
it to use this instead of the previous one what we're going to need to do is in the
recast nav mesh defaults there is a option for a link proxy class. I'm going to drop down and
use the my generate nav link. Now if I was to jump into the level and play we can now see
that our character is not only able to get down but going to be able to jump up to the areas
where they where they rubbed them. So all of these are now accessible through the nav links
but it's just a considerably quicker way. Now there are a number of more settings. I'm not going
to go into detail with them here because they allow you to define how these are set up
and again it's under recast nav mesh and you'll be looking at the nav link jump
down controls here so you've got a number of different settings here. Okay so just be aware
of that it's really useful especially if you have a large area but you need to
place the logic within the nav link as per before.